hey guys it's Jenna here and I got my
mum here today for those of you who are
in your middle age or if you're above
fifty years old and you want to start
looking after your fitness and also your
health here's what we're going to do
I'll be getting my mum through a series
of strength training exercises and these
exercises are great to strengthen your
bones and also your joints and to
prevent any unwanted injuries okay so
I'll be taking her through each workout
and what you can do is follow through
the exercises and aim to do this workout
at least two to three times weekly so
mom are you ready let's do it for each
workout we want to aim between 12 to 15
repetitions each okay so the first
exercise is squat to chair so what
you're going to do is stand slightly
wider than shoulder-width apart with
your toes pointed forward okay and you
can just place your arms in front of you
and if you can have a chance
directly behind you and so what I want
to do is push your butt back alright
good touch and stand up okay so push
your butt back even more touch and stand
up that's it so this workout will really
work on your hamstrings your quads and
also your glute muscles okay so I'm
placing my legs here because my mom's
knees should not go over my knees okay
so really push your butt back stand up
squat down - gently stand up and back
down alright good as you progress you
can remove the chair okay so this is a
squat position and always remember to
keep your chest up facing forward good
and back straight as well give me five
more very good
so down up down slow up fast slow it
down up plus two more down up one more
down and up very good so just release
all right shake it out now sit down okay
for the second exercise it's going to be
a seated overhead press so what you'll
need is a pair of really lightweight
dumbbells either one or one to three
kilos each okay so what I want you to do
is have both dumbbells just by your ears
okay next year is alright so I want you
to press straight up good and bring it
back down to your yes and press it
straight up good so bring it back down
and up good
so this workout will really work on your
shoulders up and down control down up
and down so control the workout up
straight bring it back down and up good
make sure that your back is straight and
push the dumbbells up straight up wider
wholly wider there you go that's better
up control down control and up good
control and up give me five more and
again this workout you can also do it
standing all right
good last two more wider straight back
last one more down and up very good and
drop the dumbbells give it that's me for
the third exercise we want to work on
your triceps okay this is called triceps
extension so grab only one dumbbell
we're using two kilos so bring it up
okay over your head and all I want to do
is make sure that your elbows are
pointed forward and slowly lower the
dumbbell back down and up alright good
so go down and bring it slow up don't
jerk good slow it down and bring it back
up so what you want to aim for is the 90
degree angle and your elbows should be
pointed forward and it should really
work on your tricep muscles right here
keep going
down and up and remember to breathe in
and breathe out good breathe in and
breathe out
very good so keep your back straight
don't go over this up so yeah there you
go keep going down up
stop there good keep going last few more
up do for your triceps yeah good keep
going give me three more okay down and
up lower it down elbows pointed forward
closer elbows good last two and last one
and try not to jerk and good very good
right now we're going to move on to the
mat so grab the mats the next workout is
called a bird dog this will really focus
on your core muscles okay it's not just
your abs but also your lower back and
just really strengthen the call to give
you the balance you need right so what I
want to do is get onto all fours okay on
your knees and on your pumps and shift
your body weight slightly forward so
that your shoulders are in line with
your wrists and also your palms okay so
lift your right hand up and your left
leg up and let's let's try it let's
bring it up up and to really balance
yourself you have to really tighten your
core and bring it down and the opposite
side so what you really want to aim for
is a flat back and also a strong core
okay and remember the goal is not to
rush the workout do not rush the workout
instead really engage your core suck
your belly in and feel that you're
working on your abs and also you're
finding your balance and this will also
really strengthen your joints okay your
wrists and also your legs as well keep
going up and right at the top squeeze
your butt muscles all right keep going
up good squeeze your butt
and keep going breathe in and breathe
out good so breathe out and breathe in
good flat back strong abs very good keep
going give me at least four more up
squeeze your abs squeeze your glutes
feel that your shoulder muscles are
working as well last two ball on each
side good down and always maintain a
neutral neck okay so it just gaze it
gently on the floor last one more on
each side
good one more the other side and just
rest it out very good relax and get into
a child's pose
very good so this workout will really
strengthen and work on your core muscles
okay remember it's not about rushing to
work out but rather it's about getting
and mastering proper forms okay right
the next workout is a really good
upper-body workout okay it's going to be
a modified push-up all right so for
those of you who you know you have never
done push-ups in your life before this
is what we're going to do okay
so lie flat on the mat okay the first
thing you need to do is place both pumps
right beside your chest okay so about
chest shoulder levels and the wider you
go the easier it becomes so I wanted to
just place it just I would say at the
edge of the mat okay so what I'm going
to do is lift your entire body up until
your knees keep your knees on the mat as
one unit alright ready ready mom yeah up
let's go up good down again onto the
floor relax up alright this is how you
can start to do a push-up all right
eventually what you want aim for is to
continue the push-up but without lying
straight flat onto the mat okay
so up down good bring it up push using
your chest muscles alright you will feel
on your arms and also your shoulders to
begin with but eventually I want you to
really focus on engaging your chest
muscles to push your body up up good so
relax your feet on the floor good keep
going up give me five more okay
and remember your back should be flat
okay it should be coming up as one unit
last two more it's just two more you're
doing a very good job up push up down
last one up and relax just down and
relax well done all right so this is how
you can start to do a push up remember
we all need a starting point start this
way eventually do a full knee push up
and then slowly progress onto your toes
the next workout is called hip bridge
again this workout will really focus on
your core and also you will really feel
it on your glute muscles as well so what
I wanted to do is lie flat onto the mat
face up and keep your knees bent at
about a 90 degree angle okay toes
pointed forward shoulder width apart
hands just by your sides alright so are
you ready mom
what you want to do is lift your butt
off the floor up
all right higher up higher up and
squeeze the glute muscles lower it back
down touch the mat gently and little
back up so up and down all right good so
keep going up and down good so really
squeeze your gluts down again and up
squeeze the gluts hold it for two
seconds and bring it back down
controlled and up squeeze your glutes
control and back down good up good down
and keep going okay
so imagine that's a spring pulling your
belly button straight up to give you
that resistant all right so relax your
shoulders your shoulders should always
be in contact with a mat and you should
really be moving your butt up and down
squeezing your glutes engaging your
lower abs engaging your lower back and
also your car all right keep going keep
your knees straight
all right keep your knees Center and
bring it up and down very good so up and
down so the more you bring your heels
closer to your butt the workout becomes
slightly easier okay good down
give me at least three more okay up
squeeze squeeze and down it's not going
up halfway through it's about really
engaging good very good down and give me
a high bridge up high bridge down and
last one pull it and down and just relax
well done all right relax next apps and
as a core workout did and back well
literally you will feel like a dead bug
at the end of this exercise okay so
again lie flat on the mat facing up and
what I'm going to do is bring both legs
up to a 90 degree angle okay hence on
your knees alright so what I want to do
is bring your left leg down and your
right leg up opposite it good and bring
it back in and the other opposite side
open up down and back in good good keep
going so this workout you will really
fuel on your lower abs keep going open
it up and in very good and keep going we
want to employ at least 10 repetitions
on each side okay good and again
remember it's all about your breathing
as well breathe in and breathe out
opposite side breathe in and breathe out
good so eventually as you get stronger
and if you want to challenge yourself
what you can do is lower both legs down
together so what we're starting with is
alternate legs and alternate hands
eventually you can lower both legs down
and both arms down together and bring it
back in keep going
can you give me three more on each side
mom you got this okay come on let's do
it let's go one up oh don't rush we're
not cheating right now I know when you
get tired you
she threw the word cut up and last one
more duh up the other side down and up
well done done high five give me a high
five all right when you get tired you
want to cheat it through the workout but
don't do that all right control your
muscles feel your muscles I know it's
painful but pushed through one final
workout plank everybody needs to know
how to do a proper plank so turn over
okay
face down we want to get into your final
workout you're playing alright so just
place your shoulders here good get to a
plank position alive flat onto the mat
okay to begin with this is going to be a
starting position and the first thing
you have to check is that your shoulders
okay and your elbows are close to your
body okay so keep your elbows tight and
close and that your pumps I just gently
rested onto the floor okay and your toes
should be about shoulder width apart my
mom is really excited because she has
been practicing her plank for a long
time so I know that she wants to get
straight on to her toes okay mom are you
ready you're gonna make me proud
yeah right let's get up into a plank
position up good so we want to hold this
position for 30 seconds okay so the
first thing I have to make sure is that
her body is in a straight line her back
is flat okay so her but it's not hiking
too high up and she's not a tipping her
lower back so slightly lower down a
little bit good so the whole idea about
planking is that if you want to really
tighten your core slightly lower down
good and really suck your belly in
breathe in and breathe out relax keep
your neck and neutral keep your back
flat and you want to maintain this
position okay I'm gonna just tilt her
hips slightly typically some of us will
have a little bit of muscle imbalance
all right good
keep breathing another five more seconds
alright five four three two and one well
done relax
good job so just know that if you're
shaking it is absolutely normal
that
means that you're recruiting you're
engaging all your muscles okay so it's
absolutely normal to feel that you're
shaking if you're a beginner and you
find that this is challenging then what
you can do is start on your knees first
all right mom well done
get into a child's pose and just relax
good job just relax I've given her a
really good workout so if you can I
would encourage you to do this workout
at least two to three times weekly okay
aim to slowly progress in for 12 to 15
repetitions per exercise and as you
progress you can go for more repetitions
alright so strength training is
extremely important it will really have
to strengthen your bones your joints and
also to prevent any unwanted injuries
especially at all age good job don't
forget to look at her sweating you feel
good you good yeah you should be
sweating like my mom here okay don't
forget to share this video get your mom
or your friends to get active do this
workout and be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos and also workout challenges and
stay healthy alright
even at whatever age high five all the
Bears